all right guys
bang bang very excited about this i've
got the founders of pop chew here how
are you guys
doing great right awesome let's just
jump right into this uh you guys are the
masterminds behind bitcoin pizza with me
uh let's just talk about one what was
bitcoin pizza
uh and how did it go right out of the
gate yeah
uh bitcoin pizza was our first launch
um for popshu it was really our take out
can we leverage a community that's super
engaged super powerful
and build a food brand around it uh that
again just like further engages the
community and audience in a really
deep and really connecting away right
like if you think about it
food is one of those things that's like
super super personal it's like you're
literally getting invited to pomp's
dinner table
uh when you're taking a you know a slice
of bitcoin pizza so
yeah super exciting got it and nick how
uh how did it go from like a statistic
standpoint
it was incredible uh on launch date we
were turning on twitter
uh like 15 million impressions i'm like
that like 100 000 people on our website
the first day
almost 100k in sales uh over the course
of the seven-day event
stoke restaurant partners uh we raised
fifteen thousand dollars for the human
rights foundation which is incredible
yeah and i think part of what people
don't realize is you know there's all
this kind of traffic
and um uh eventually stephen colbert and
folks covered it
uh but it was only available in 10
cities right
and only in the united states so talk a
little bit about kind of operationally
when somebody orders a pizza
uh through bitcoin pizza what happens in
terms of
from that order to them actually
receiving the pizza yeah so what we're
doing at hofstra is essentially building
a network
of independent mom-and-pop restaurants
right we're basically aggregating all
these restaurants together building a
network
and then basically creating a platform
for creators to launch brands on top of
um and so with bitcoin pizza we built a
network of 44 independent mon pad
pizzerias across the country in 10 key
cities
from new york to l.a to san francisco to
miami
a handful of other cities um put them
all together
layered the brand and at the end of the
day like they were excited about it for
a number of reasons right like for one
they get extra demand through their
through the businesses right we're
bringing to more orders than they would
normally get
and then two they're getting more
exposure as a restaurant
they had their logos listed on our
landing page people could go in person
visit these restaurants
um it was really compelling for them to
be a part of the departure platform
got it and so one of the things that i
think people didn't understand but it's
important to me and i think important to
you guys was
we basically would go to these local
pizzerias and we'd say hey
uh you're going to make the normal pizza
that you make it's going to go into our
box
so there's not a ton of like operational
complexities that get
created for the local business but also
too is we're going to bring you orders
but you're going to sell that pizza for
the exact same price that you would
normally sell it so we don't eat into
the margin of the local pizzeria either
and so it's kind of this like win-win
where uh we get to use their
infrastructure and their years of hard
work of building out
kind of the operational excellence that
they have as a local pizzeria and
obviously great food
and in return we're going to bring you a
bunch of orders as well and so
i think that was kind of a key piece
here was the
capital that was being donated was
really kind of profit on top of what a
small business would normally make
and really that's where um you know you
create this kind of unique situation
where the local business wins uh the
human right
foundation wins and then also the
customer wins because they're able to
get kind of this bitcoin pizza so it's
pretty incredible model
uh when you start to understand how this
network that you guys are building
uh at pop2 is able to be leveraged for
something like a bitcoin pizza
exactly and i think like something
that's super impressive right is we were
covering about 10
of your audience geographically right
like literally 10
and we did 100k in top line sales for
all these restaurants
um and so you know when we start adding
more and more locations over time right
like our goal is to eventually be able
to cover
you know as close to 100 as possible um
the business becomes extremely
compelling
um and you know again the other sort of
really powerful thing about it is
we're working with restaurants that like
already know how to do this right like
we're going to pizzerias and saying like
here's a pizza
uh we're going to burger restaurants and
being like here's a burger menu right
it's like it's food that they already
know how to make they're already
excellent at doing it
and then through pop shoot through the
creators you know we're getting these
people that are
juggernauts literally at customer
acquisition
at loyalty at retention and like doing
what they do best to bring the demand
to these small businesses absolutely
really crazy thing
about bitcoin pizza that was the
restaurants that were selling
bitcoin pizzas were making more money
selling bitcoin pizzas and they were
making selling their own pizza so we
didn't use
a third-party marketplace to sell the
coin pizzas all the orders were direct
so there's no doordash there's no
reads typically those platforms are
taking 30
of the margin away from the restaurant
we charge a low flat fee per order
and typically the restaurant was making
four five six eight dollars more per
order selling on bitcoin pizza than they
were their own equivalent pizza on door
dash
yeah it's pretty incredible when you
start to realize that economically they
were actually incentivized
uh to make the bitcoin pizzas over other
types of orders
because they literally just put more
money in their pocket at the end of each
order right
literally i mean we had a handful of
pizzerias that were uh telling their
customers like on instagram or twitter
like hey go order bitcoin pizza right
like they wanted them to go and order
from this like third-party brand versus
their own yeah
and nick maybe talk a little bit about
what's the plan now uh moving forward
with bitcoin pizza in terms of getting
more locations and kind of moving it
from more of a one-off type thing
to something that'll be persistently
available for folks yeah so obviously
the response was insane
a ton of folks reaching out to us at you
know atlanta and phoenix and all these
different places where we weren't
um and so right now we're building that
restaurant network we're expanding into
a bunch of new cities all across the u.s
we're looking at things like how do we
go international how do we go to canada
which you know
obviously palms audiences is global um
but our plan is to bring the brand back
um
shortly and launching far more markets
for a much more
long-term run yeah and one of the things
that i didn't understand until
afterwards that you guys helped me get
educated on so maybe you can educate the
audience here
is just compared to a traditional
food brand being able to go to kind of
40 locations immediately have
uh national coverage even though it's
only in those 10 cities we still were in
the kind of ten major cities in the
united states
uh that takes a really long time for
kind of a traditional brand to do
so what are some of the comps that we
can use to understand
uh you know getting to 50 plus locations
from a timeline perspective
uh and also like how difficult that is
for a traditional mom and pop or brick
and mortar type
um restaurant brand yeah i mean i think
the direct comparison right like if you
take a brand like sweet green it took
them literally like 12 years to get to
100 locations
um and you have to think about like
there's a lot of these companies out
there whether it's traditional
restaurants or even some of these like
ghost kitchen companies they're all
building physical infrastructure
and that takes a lot of time it takes a
lot of permitting
um you know to be able to sell alcohol
to sell food
and i think like really what we're doing
is it's sort of turning around right and
if you look at a traditional restaurant
i mean 30 of uh of a traditional
restaurant's audience
um actually comes back a second time
right so pretty pretty low
um and you know best in class take
someone like shake shack
55 of their customers come back second
time repeat purchase um
and for us like really flipping that on
the head and saying like hey
let's go to creators let's go to the
folks
that know what they're doing on the
customer demand side know what they're
doing on the loyalty side customer
retention and basically build this like
product
that you know enables them to bring the
demand side
to the restaurants uh that are great at
doing the food right like
if you look at a lot of these
restaurants today they're like just now
getting into like email marketing
right or like an app that displays a
menu but you know
coming from obviously like tech right
like we know that there's a lot more
product experiences that we can build
um that are far beyond you know what
these like restaurants are just now
starting to do
and so we're sort of approaching this
from the opposite side of traditional
restaurants
what's crazy to me is take a sweet green
as the example there
uh it took them 12 years to get to 100
locations
and then they're able to kind of have a
bunch of you know sales and throughput
but they also spend a bunch of money on
marketing and to reach profitability is
is pretty difficult for a lot of those
types of brands i think a company like
yum brands right like yum brands has kfc
pizza hut taco bell they've spent
literally like hundreds of millions of
dollars on marketing
and like years and years and years to
grow their brands into like what they
are today
right um and again with like poppy the
entire idea is like
let's take these people that have the
audience already and like just plug them
right in
um into the restaurant so i'm not even
really that
big from an audience perspective
compared to some of the people you could
go do this with right i got a million
people on twitter
uh but a lot of the other audiences
aren't really that big i mean 200 000 on
youtube etc
i'm guessing that the plan from a pop
chew perspective is just go
get the biggest folks possible um that
have you know much much larger audiences
you can imagine if
uh somebody with 50 100 million
followers on a platform did this
uh it would be absolutely nuts yeah
absolutely and so like
our goal with pottery is like really to
build this as a platform right there's
the food like works for a wide variety
of creators right you can be a huge like
fitness
creator right and maybe a salad bowl or
um you know smoothie or something like
that makes a ton of sense for you and
your audience maybe you're a gamer and a
burglar makes sense right there's like a
lot of different avenues
to get into food for a variety of
different types of creators out there
and that's not even touching like all
the food creators that are out there
right like if you go on take talk or
youtube or instagram like food is
literally everywhere
um right like we're talking to a wide
variety of creators right now that are
in our pipeline about launching their
food brands coming up here
yeah and nick talk a little bit about
the advantages that you have
um from a pop shoe perspective of like
no cat-backs and no food costs and just
like why this almost like asset light
model
makes so much more sense today if you
want to start a restaurant versus going
and actually doing the brick and mortar
type strategy yeah so uh you know my
thesis
today is if you had a million dollars
for the restaurant the first thing you
wouldn't
the last thing you would do is plow it
into real estate the last thing you do
is go build
an infrastructure right like you would
figure out a way to build a brand and
figure out
you should get the product of people
like why would you put it into brick and
mortar in
new york city where i am for example um
and so pop shoe operates with no food
costs no capex no labor anything like
that
we're leveraging the expertise and the
infrastructure that already exists with
our restaurant partners and some of
those folks are in ghost kitchens
um to create a revenue opportunity for
these folks to
to drive our brands to grow our brands
very very quickly
um which allows us to get to a hundred
locations i think we're here we'll be at
100 locations by the end of this year
um less than 12 months after starting
right again compared that sweet great it
took them 12 years to do that
this is just a super capital efficient
way to grow a food brand
and capitalize on the opportunities yeah
and it feels like
really you can replicate a lot of the
same effort right in terms of building a
brand marketing
doing a lot of these various uh
components that we know is
uh important for the brick and mortars
but you're able to essentially
borrow or rent somebody else's
infrastructure without having to pay for
it
and they make more money along the way
right like it's such a win-win-type
uh model that i think you know it's kind
of a no-brainer as to why
uh folks are gonna flock to this yeah i
mean especially on the restaurant side
right like
uh we were you know nick has has been
the ghost kitchen in virtual brand space
for five years
and as we were calling up restaurants
pitching them on like hey like let's
work with popchi let's you know
do bitcoin pizza uh we were actually
surprised at
how easily it was to get them on board
um just because the pitch to the
restaurant is so so compelling right
it's
it's purely incremental uh demand that
we're driving
right it's you were already paying for
the space you already were paying for
the staff
uh oftentimes you even had some
ingredients laying around um and now
we're just providing more demand for you
to put all that to use
and you're able to do it at a lower cost
than you normally would
um and so the pitch to the restaurants
was was just super compelling
and the picture the creator is also like
really compelling too right like
um i mean you know this better than
everyone but um
you know there's not a ton of effort
that goes in from the creator side in
order to launch this right
input on the brand oftentimes like we're
talking to creators now that already
have a brand
established and we're just like putting
that on the packaging and then it's up
to them to go and engage their audience
right literally doing what they do best
already every single day
um to get people to go and eat from
their restaurant
um and again like food is one of those
things that's just like
so so personal um in a way that like
merch for example
um just isn't hey guys what's going on
before we continue with this awesome
episode i want to quickly talk about our
sponsor kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app
you'll have your portfolio in your
pocket you can track your portfolio
see who the winners and losers are every
day track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
crackit's been a long time supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go
and download their new mobile app all
right let's get back into this episode i
hope you're enjoying this one
and so talk through a little bit uh
maybe tell the story of like how you
guys convinced me to do this
because i think that's a pretty good
example and uh
you know eventually not only did i enjoy
working with you guys and it worked but
i ended up actually investing in pop2
the business itself
um so i'm a pretty big believer in the
model but just kind of tell that story
uh to help people understand um really
you know the the
effort level needed from the creator
side yeah
so i think we like approached you maybe
it was like three or four months ago at
this point
um and initially approached you as an
investor right and the goal was like hey
like pomp you know
you know a handful of creators like
would be great to have you on the cap
table
um and i think you had come back to us
and basically said like hey like this is
super exciting the creators i've talked
to are really interested in food
but i think that this might be like too
time consuming or too like time
intensive for the creators to actually
do
um and so nick and i threw together like
literally that night
uh bang bang pizza right so like
obviously like we follow you we watch
your videos
we know that big things tagline um and
so we threw together bang bang pizza
send it over to you um and you know that
was sort of off the races i think you
have something around like
uh a rewarding hustle right and i think
like that was a perfect example
of um you know showing you like here's
how easy it can be
uh to launch it how about you be our
first creator um and so
yeah from there right you you said um
let's actually do bitcoin pizza let's
make it even bigger let's launch on big
one one pizza day
um make a splash so uh that's what we
did
and i think like the great thing was
like you know our initial proposition
was like let's launch in one city
uh and then we ended up launching in 10
cities across the us
so just again it goes to show like the
scale and how fast
uh brands like this and can be spun up
yeah i think what's so fascinating about
it is as you
um kind of showed me hey here's what the
boxes would look like here's the menu
like
you start to understand like oh wait a
second the infrastructure provider is
really important you guys did a great
job with it
um but really the kind of responsibility
i have
in this scenario uh is to simply
promote it right and and to kind of be
the marketing arm if you or the
distribution arm
for a brand that i actually believe in
and helped craft
and then you guys kind of take all that
complex operational
uh components and you bring it in the
background and so literally i don't even
know how you call the pizza place
and get them signed up and like all the
things that uh i would have thought
would have been really difficult and
and uh hard and i wouldn't personally
have done
i think you know this model of you guys
take care of that and it's really just
asking the creator to be the
kind of marketing arm of a food brand uh
ends up being really interesting and it
goes back to this whole idea of
you know you can go and try to strike a
marketing deal with somebody
for a food brand or you can own the food
brand right and always owning equity if
it's successful it's going to be
much much more lucrative and much more
rewarding i think
than uh trying to go get you know
somebody to sponsor you or sponsor your
videos or whatever from there
100 right like if you look at travis
scott for example right like he did a
deal with mcdonald's
it was a phenomenal deal right like
travis scott this like mega star guy
uh literally drove so much demand that
mcdonald's of all companies was
literally running out of burger meat and
lettuce at
key locations uh so sort of like insane
um but the thing is he got paid less
than two percent of the revenue that he
was responsible for generating
right and you know you look at what he's
doing now
right he's he's sort of like been
educated he has his own waterline
um right he's starting to build his own
brands because he understands
now that like hey this is the actual way
to build equity
um and you know this is this is the
future of how brands are gonna be
established
absolutely what uh what's next from a
pop chew perspective how are you guys
thinking about
kind of where you go next and how you
continue grow the business yeah
so there's a couple of key things um so
so one
key thesis that we have is that it's not
just about what you
uh food is a lot more about the
experience that you have
right um there's restaurants that like i
personally go to
just because like the music is good um
and no one is like touching this in the
food delivery world if you look at
doordash or ubrics or any of these
players
you scroll through a list of restaurants
you scroll through a menu you place your
order and it shows up in a brown paper
bag
that's sort of the end of the day right
um and so for us we really think about
what what does this experiential
component look like
um and that's the thing that we're going
to be advancing on the product side
and that's looking at things like drops
integrating merch
integrating content integrating
community right so think about
right now like you have all these kids
who you know eat dinner sometimes alone
like in their bedroom right
playing video games what if you could
also just like eat with a community that
you're in
um and this is like this like really
powerful sort of example
um and so that's what we're gonna be
focused on the product side and then
on the sort of like launch operation
side uh we have a
slew of creators that we're talking to
right now that are in our pipeline
and we're working on food brands with
and we'll be launching those
across a network of restaurants that
were as nick mentioned growing to 100 by
the end of the year
yeah it uh it feels like
somebody is going to win this category
i'm going to build the infrastructure
and kind of the marketplace
it's just a matter of of execution right
it's very clear that there's a market
opportunity it just comes out of the
execution piece 100
i think like you know being fast is
super super important in the space
um i think that's what nick and i really
specialize in um you know i've spent the
last
like four or five years working in
marketplace operations businesses
um you know dropped out of school and
just like needed to get going and fired
up to start working
um nick you know again like last four or
five years working in ghost kitchens and
virtual brands
knows that space like the back of his
hand uh we just made our first um
offer to a guy who's been the gm at
speak green at chipotle
um and you know totally understands like
sourcing and restaurant acquisition and
how to train staff
um and so you know we're all geared up
to get going
nick before we uh we go to wrap up
what's the one thing that you learned
during the virtual um kind of brand or
ghost kitchen experience
what's like the biggest takeaway that
you had or the most surprising thing
i think we got to talk about it right i
think this idea that
a single brick-and-mortar location can
be a hub
a a business with multiple revenue
opportunities a business with
with multiple brands underneath it this
idea that like you don't have to
be a business owner who's like
struggling to get by because you're only
selling this one brand like you can
leverage the expertise and experience of
folks like rasheer and i folks like you
know pomp if you want to take on a
pizza brand um and you can create this
like new
economic paradigm for yourself as a
restaurant donor by leveraging these
these different opportunities and i
think for me as someone who spent a ton
of time working with restaurateurs chefs
owners things like that like that's what
really excites me about this opportunity
is that i think we can really create
value for restaurant owners
yeah i i completely agree i ask everyone
the same three questions so i'm not
letting you two get out of here without
asking the same questions
uh what is the most important book that
each one of you have uh have read
oh interesting nick i'll let you go
first um
why we sleep uh by um
[Music]
matthew matthew i forget his last name
but yeah yeah
that's a great one and just the only
thing your body needs is to sleep if you
don't sleep you're gonna get all these
crazy diseases like
just just rest your body and then give
your body
i'm i'm a complete convert it's funny
that you said this
uh because the next question is usually
what is uh
everyone's sleep schedule because uh the
folks over at eight sleep
i started sleeping on their
thermoregulated bed and
not only do i now sleep like a baby
eight or nine hours a night uh but i
literally
begged them to let me invest in the
business afterwards so
i uh i'm a big big believer of uh of
sleep for sure
rasheer what is uh what's your book uh
my book this is probably a bad answer
but uh i i actually really enjoyed the
steve jobs book uh by walter isaacson
and i think like why would that be a bad
answer
i don't know it's not one of the popular
answers i guess
uh but that but that's okay um i think
for me it was really about like
uh you know finding someone who
um is really like dedicated to their
craft um
you know really like understands really
what they're building and why they're
building it like really understands the
customer
um in a really deep way right i think
that's like one of the things that sort
of apple differentiated themselves on
um i think that really stands out to me
yeah that's a great answer
uh last question aliens are you guys
believers or non-believers
100 real uh 100 the universe is so huge
like
it's it's stupid to think that we're the
only ones here
i agree i absolutely agree it's all
right the nasa chief
yeah the nasa chief he uh he recently
came out he said he thinks that there's
gonna be intelligent life as well
so i think we're uh we're getting more
allies on this side of the uh the debate
what one question do you guys have for
me to uh to finish up
um interesting okay uh
what is the most exciting part of your
day every day
waking up easily i i'm like a big
uh i think a lot of people forget that
uh
life is finite and um just getting to
wake up every day
is in some crazy way like you're
very you know kind of uh further ahead
than some other people
um and so when that's like the the bar
of quality for the day is like did i get
to wake up today
then uh everything else kind of you know
seems pretty minuscule and not that
important and it's pretty easy to be
happy
so easily that that's uh that's the
thing makes sense yeah i
uh those uh those like good morning
texts or the good morning tweets that
you do
those are great did i get uh
i'm a big believer that like uh you you
create the energy of the day
by uh by just bringing the energy so i
don't know
it's just uh that's my way of living my
life worked out so far and
i'll keep doing it nice all right where
can we send people
uh let's send them two places one uh
maybe let's send them to uh
follow you guys on twitter uh for pop
chew and then what's the
website for uh bitcoin pizza for uh for
them to uh to go check that out before
we relaunch it
yep so the website for bitcoin says eat
bitcoin pizza.com it's a pretty
straightforward
all right and then twitter yep on
twitter uh you can find us at
eat popchew.com or sorry eat just epoch
you with the handle
uh and then my personal twitter is
rasheed r-u-s-h-i-k-h
all right nick i'm nikki sapp and i cky
sop and we're hiring so folks that are
interested
shoot this email that's a great plug
they're hiring if you want to go help
build bitcoin pizza
go apply all right fellas thank you guys
so much for uh for doing this
i'm excited to keep going and uh and
then it's not only gonna be a bitcoin
pizza show obviously we got plenty more
people to uh to onboard and keep
building the business so
thanks for so much for coming on and
we'll do it again in the future sounds
good thanks for having us